yes there are questions about
accountability will this hurt how the
community views the raiders or will this
impact allegiant stadium which was
partially financed through taxpayer
dollars
one area of concern is why john gruden
coached last sunday's game if mark davis
knew about the emails on friday since
then there has been sharp outcry about
the emails from local organizations and
community leaders the tampa bay
buccaneers and video game maker e-a were
quick to remove their affiliation to
gruden i asked governor sisalak if the
raiders have done enough to feel good
about the tremendous investment made for
them in the community he said they
invested in the stadium only not the
team i'm proud of what we've done with
the stadium it's attracted a lot of
people into town
i think the comments that coach gruden
made were deplorable and despicable and
do not represent any part of the state
of nevada that i represent and it's time
for us to move on
allegiant stadium cost 1.9 billion
dollars with 750 million of that coming
from municipal bonds and a special rooms
tax denise